Super Bowl viewers on Sunday will be
watching more than the game but
commercials have also become must-see TV
first on CBS this morning we have the
debut of one of this year's commercials
a Toyota ad featuring a very special
athlete Tony Harris is a defensive back
for the East Los Angeles College Huskies
in high school along with playing
football she was the homecoming queen
that's right she Harris will be one of
the few women ever to play college
football she's received multiple
scholarship offers to four-year programs
and while she still hasn't decided which
one to accept she has set her sights on
an even bigger goal I first developed
that interest in football when I was
about four between four and six years
old people around me they weren't too
fond of me playing football they said
that I could get hurt a lot easier
playing with guys what motivates me most
the play is people tell me that I can't
I love to prove people wrong I was
kicked off the team when I was younger
because I was a girl but once I got
older and into high school I mean it
still was hard but I just tried to pave
my way through no matter what anybody
said it's my dream and I'm gonna protect
it at any cost
playing football at the college level
makes me feel very proud of what I am
doing is 80% mental and only 20%
physical so you have to have a different
mentality to play the game before a
message that I would like to send to
younger girls is to keep your dream
alive nothing's impossible
you can add God for something but you
have to make out halfway Tony Harris
they said she was too small when Toyota
contacted me about the Super Bowl ad I
was literally in the locker room getting
ready to get dressed and I heard my
phone ding and I saw that they wanted to
shoot a Super Bowl commercial I've never
been a big fan of assumptions I want to
be the first female in a field where
being a role model it's an honor but
it's also a privilege because not every
day everybody can stand up and be a role
model for other people and it's kind of
hard it's a lot of pressure but I mean
I'm just paving the way for the next
little girl that's gonna come along and
be a role model as well paving the way
and here is the premiere of the full
Superbowl ad featuring Tony Harris from
Toyota a sponsor of our show CBS this
morning
[Music]
they've said a lot of things about Tony
Harris
they said she was too small
[Music]
they said she was too slow
[Applause]
[Music]
to week
they said she'd never get to the next
level
[Applause]
[Music]
never inspire a new generation never get
a football scholarship
[Music]
people have made a lot of assumptions
about donut but I've never been a big
fan of assumptions and neither have we
introducing the hybrid that will shatter
perceptions the all-new built for speed
rap or hybrid Toyota let's go places
[Music]
wow she's incredible I can't wait to
meet her in person I know and going back
to even her childhood it was always a
case of you can't box me in she was
homecoming queen she said she liked prom
she liked dresses that didn't mean that
she didn't like football and so many
people like to stereotype or one way or
the other
she's got a big future ahead of her
wishing her good luck in CBS Sports
we'll bring you all the action of Super
Bowl 53 beginning with the pregame
activities starts as early as 2:00 and
then 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time and you can
see it all right here on CBS